cette partie là c'est juste pour me dire
fais attention c'est presque cuit mais
je sors pas tout de suite je finis à
l'oeil dans la famille sable et de
lancer voici le petit dernier qui sort
du four
un petit gâteau aux éclats de noisettes
je fais très attention par rapport à son
temps de cuisson
parce que pour qu'il rende au niveau de
son parfum un maximum de saveur il faut
vraiment que la cuisson soit d'une
précision diabolique mais presque nature
aux pépites de chocolat ou désormais à
la noisette
ici on fait des sablés depuis 1953
cette année là un apprenti boulanger de
lancer doit faire un fond de tarte
mais patatras il rate la recette il en
fait des biscuits et les offres aux
clients tous les trouve délicieux les
sables et de lancer son nez cinquante
mille biscuits sortent chaque jour de
l'atelier avec toujours la même recette
toujours les mêmes gestes
une tradition que perpétue le petit fils
du créateur des sables ou non seulement
c'est un héritage mais en plus c'est
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur parce
que il ya une histoire derrière ce sable
et cette histoire est bien maintenant
c'est à moi d'en faire l'enfer la suite
des gens avant moi ont fait un travail
formidable à moi de continuer à nous de
continuer à faire ce sable et tous les
jours de la même façon et ne surtout pas
changer son goût les gars tous sont
vendues en boulangerie dans les
épiceries fines et en grandes surfaces
autour de lancer dans un rayon de 200 km
les gourmands les trouve aussi dans la
boutique attenante à l'atelier les gens
ont besoin de reprendre confiance en
confiance pardon entre ce qu'ils mangent
et d'où ça vient
donc nous non seulement on leur montre
d'où ça vient et en plus on leur fait
déguster et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très important pour le consommateur
depuis 65 ans les habits de lancer pour
partie de l'histoire locale
ils sont inscrits à l'inventaire du
patrimoine culinaire du centre val de
loire